Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricardo Lops, and
today I'm joined for a second time by Dr.
Steve Kin. Uh, LAST time we talked about some
of the topics he explores in his book Rebuilding
Economics from the Top Down, and today we're going
to focus a little bit more on the economic,
the economics or the economic consequences of climate change
and the, the Iran war and its impact on
the global market. So Dr. Kin, welcome back to
the show. It's a pleasure to everyone.
Thank you.
Uh, OK, so last time we touched a little
bit on this topic, but I would like to
explore it with you today a little bit more.
So when it comes to, uh, climate change, what
are the most probable Economic consequences that can derive
from it. I mean, and of course if you
want to talk about the risks associated with climate
change that are not exclusively economic, please feel free
to do so. But what would you say about
that?
Well, in a simple line, it's the extinction of
humanity. That's what's in life, that's what's at stake.
And there's been the, the way in which it's
been put across by economists has completely trivialized the
scale of what we're going through, and that's what
I've been working on and exposing for the last
6 or 7 years so far unsuccessfully. But if
economists, if we continue down the path we're on
now, human civilization will not exist by 2100. And
humanity itself will be a question mark as well.
But I mean, would you put a number of
that on that? What is the likelihood that by
the end of the century or by the beginning
of next century, humanity will no longer be here?
I won't go for humanity's extinction, but I say
the potential if we continue on the current course,
that the chance of extinction of human civilization by
2100 is 100%.
Uh, HUMAN civilization. So I, I mean, what would
that imply exactly? Would that imply that the kind
of, uh, societies as they operate today, at least
the more advanced industrialized
opposed to there'll be hunters and gatherers, there'll be
hunters and gatherers left somewhere in the world. One
or two countries might survive, perhaps, but fundamentally, and
what I'm saying, I mean, that that's OK, that
sounds outrageous, the guy's a nutcase, yada yada yada,
usual sort of thing. I'm channeling uh Tim Lenton,
who's a professor of climate science at Exeter University,
and like Tim, who's quite a, you know, quite
a reserved person in general, was asked at a
conference about six months ago, you can find it
on YouTube, what's the chance of human civilization existing
by 2100 if we continue on our current course,
he said not a chance. But
if we continue in our current course, what does
that imply? I mean, how many degrees of warming
are we talking about?
2 or 3.
2 or 3, so 2 or 3 degrees, uh,
above pre-industrial levels is enough for civilization to collapse,
wipe
civilization out,
yes. Yeah, and, uh, I, I, I mean, we're
already above 1.5 degrees, right? So we're
approaching, we're probably going to hit 1.9 next year
courtesy of the El Nino, which is going to
boost temperatures by at least 0.2 of a degree
and maybe 0.4 only temporarily, of course, it won't
be a permanent kick, but that particular. El Nino
coming our way. I've seen estimates that it will
raise global temperatures by up to 0.4 of one
degree.
But is this reversible at all, and if it
is res reversible,
we, we wait 20 or maybe 20 or 30
million years for a new species to evolve, and
then there'll be, you know, then we'll be wait
for the carbon to to be taken out of
the atmosphere. It it only, it took 65 million
years to go from the dinosaurs to us, so
let's say another 65 million years from us to
the next intelligent species.
OK, but what I'm asking you is the way
that our societies currently operate, would it be, what
kinds of changes would we need to our economy,
to our, I don't know, transport systems and to
everything that uses energy for us to be able
to keep this down to 1.5 degrees or even
possibly reverse it.
We're not going to do that. OK, this is,
this, this we can have fantasy conversations about what
would happen if we did X, Y, and Z.
Are we going to do X, Y, and Z?
The answer obviously is no. Uh, WE'RE, we're putting,
we're putting 40 billion tons of carbon dioxide into
the atmosphere every year now, roughly speaking. Uh, IF
you plot back to, uh, 1750 when fundamentally when
we began, uh, the industrial revolution and fit, uh,
fit an exponential curve from the level and in,
in, um, 1750. At, at the rate of growth,
uh, it, it's just for an exponential curve, it
fits it like a glove. So what it's basically
saying, all, all we've done with what, with what
we've, we've, we've produced hot air about reducing carbon
dioxide. In terms of impacting the trend from 1750,
we've done nothing whatsoever. We're still on that trend.
And that means we're going to continue pumping, pumping
carbon dioxide into the atmosphere. The temperature is going
to continue rising, and then we're going to start
triggering the carbon sinks that are currently or carbon
reservoirs that are currently in some of the tipping
points. So, uh, the amount of carbon in the
permafrost is of the order of twice the amount
of carbon already in the atmosphere. A similar thing
applies to ocean and methane hydrates. Everything we're doing
is about we've we've done our bit and now
nature's going to show what it can do. So
the whole idea that we can limit the uh
carbon dioxide to, um, as if we're the as
if our inputs are the only source of it,
it it's clearly it's a major source, it's it's
a tiny source compared to the carbon cycle, but
adding, it's a bit like a bath, if you've
got a, if you've got your bath running, and
you've got to set it up so that the
rate of inflow from the tap is exactly equal
to the rate of outflow through the bottom. And
it stays at its constant level, and then you
put a thimbleful of of water every, every minute
from your own hands. That thimbleful of water will
make sure you over overfill the bath, the bath.
So the whole idea that, um, you know, it's
our tiny contributions. I've I've seen so many denials,
I just get used to responding to the talking
points they put to me, and one of them
is it's such a tiny, how that's so small
compared to the carbon cycle. But the carbon cycle
was balanced, we've had a tiny amount to it.
And we're getting to the point where those with
previous storage systems for carbon are now reaching the
point where they might be tipped as well, and
when they get tipped, we really don't know. Well,
scientists will have some idea of estimating it, but
the amount of carbon, that's gonna mean that the
natural sinks would start adding carbon if we stop.
So we are, it's absolutely critical that we stop
putting carbon dioxide into the atmosphere and reduce our
energy consumptions radically. We will not do anything about
it until events like we saw in Nepal, which
may or may not have been a climate change
event. I'm aware there is a dispute at the
moment as to whether that was triggered by climate
change or not, but events like that will become
commonplace around the world. Now what that means is
forget about the the industrial structures will be washed
away in serious storms, fields destroyed in droughts. I
mean this, this is all the sort of stuff
which you can't normally talk about because you're seen
as a lunatic. I just thought I'd start in
a lunatic mode now and then go back and
explain why the trivial estimates of damages from climate
change that economists have made are complete garbage.
But if we look at a country like China
where people have been investing a lot on renewable
energy and decarbonizing their energy systems, do you think,
and of course again this is a hypothetical, but
do you think that if at least In Europe
and North America, people would invest as much in
renewable energy and decarbonization as they're doing in China.
That that could make a difference.
That could make a difference, but we're not going
to do it, OK. We're not gonna do it
until large numbers of white people start to die.
That's the we will, we will not realize how
serious this is until what happened in Nepal, and
again I'm saying I don't know that that's global
warming cause, what happens in Nepal happens regularly to
white people. In rich countries, and then we realized
holy shit, this is serious, and we might finally
realize this is not a case of cost-benefit analysis,
which is the way the economists put it across,
it's a case of existentialism. Do we exist or
not as a civilization? And with the amount of
energy we're putting into the atmosphere by trapping sun's
energy, not letting it escape courtesy of the absorbing
of the capacity of, pardon me, of greenhouse gasses
to retain more of the sun's energy. Keep on
doing this and, The stability that was the basis
of our civilization, the stable temperature, we're destroying that
so rapidly. The rate of, there's only one time
in the history of the planet since since animals
evolved that the temperature has risen more quickly than
it's rising right now, and that's in the 10
to 30 years, or maybe not quite sure how
many years, but maybe 3 to 30 years after
the meteor that wiped out the dinosaurs. Because that
meteor, as well as devastation it did on its
impact, hit a Carboniferous set of rocks and increased
the carbon content of the planet by a factor
of 5, roughly speaking, from say about 500 parts
per million to 2000, 2.500. And 100,000 years of
global warming. The rate of increase in temperature there
was in terms of raising the rate of increase
in temperature in million degrees per million years. That
was a rate of 600,000 degrees per million years.
We are only doing 6000 degrees per million years,
our increase in temperature right now, but that is
faster than the other 5, the other major extinctions
on the planet. So we are increasing temperature. 10
to 60 times faster than all the other, all
the natural events which led to rising temperature and
hence extinction, and we are imagining that we will
be able to do things which in the past
sent 80% of of of uh animal species extinct.
We're imagining we can do that while maintaining the
economy at the same time. Yeah,
what would you say to those people who over
the years have been saying that, oh we don't
need to worry about climate change that much, just
let the capitalist economic system work as freely as
possible and eventually we will have a Technological solution
to it because someone, an innovator out there will
come up with something to solve this issue. I
mean, do you think that just letting things play
out without much intervention is a good idea at
this point? Oh, it's
a great idea if you want to go extinct.
OK, uh, the, the, the, I can actually illustrate
why, why we're being deluded about it with a
cartoon that I did with a colleague of mine,
Miguel Guerre, which I'm putting in my book, um,
uh, How Economists will destroy Capitalism. So this, this
is showing, this is the temperature profile over the
last 300,000 years or 4 roughly 400,000 years of
human, of of of human existence. That's what we're
doing right now, that's the temperature spike rating at
the moment, OK. Uh, SO these are the parts
of the slightly blacker bit you can see this
because those are actual measurements. Uh, THEN there's estimates,
uh, in the year between 0 and 2000. That's
when civilization began, roughly here at civilization. We climbed
out of an ice age to reach it, OK,
so the ice age was about 8 °C as
an average temperature, whereas ours is about 14 degrees,
so it's a 6 degree change in temperature to
go from the ice age. And we all have
knowledge at least to some extent of what that
was like, and there was a previous peak which
is called the Emian 130,000 years ago. You can
see that average temperature then was higher during the
Amian, then these two little peaks down here. Humanity
evolved around here. OK, now we didn't create civilization
until we got up here. OK. And the question
is why? OK, well, down here, the moisture content
of the of the air was about 50% lower
than it is up here. So there was, you
couldn't, you didn't have enough moisture to maintain agriculture.
Here, it was probably too hot, too volatile. Too
radical, unstable a climate system, we're heading right for
it. We're going to blast past that one in
the next 10 or 20 years quite probably. Now
that's just a peak, it didn't cause extinctions obviously
because we, we as a civilizer, as a species
we evolved here and made it to here, but,
In none of these previous peaks did we develop
anything resembling a civilization. So the fact we developed
a civilization relies upon what you might call Goldilocks
conditions that applied across the, the, this particular peak.
These are all called Milankovic cycles, by the way.
These are cycles caused by the change in the
rotation of the Earth around the sun. Now if
you look at this is taking a longer look,
this is the last 20,000 years. So that's the
period that we managed to develop civilization, highly stable.
And what economists have done, and this is I'm
making a bit of a a little um Um,
no, sort of parody of, of time versus space
here because if you look at what we've done
over time, then we've gone through this way. That's
as bad as, um, hunter-gatherers. We start developing civilization
when we get the, we start climbing up the
hill. This is going through time. We finally get
to modern civilization and in modern civilization we range
from Eskimos at -7 to people in the Caribbean
at +35, that's the sort of range. Now. William
Nordhaus looked at that and all economists can see
is the current system, they don't see through time,
so they saw the pattern across space, and he
said, oh, that looks like a parabola. So he
said what we can do is get all our
young students to go and measure the shape of
the of of the economy over space and then
we can build an estimate of the shape of
this parabola. And all we have to do then
is pretend that the shape of the hill this
way is exactly the same as the shape through
time. So you pretend what we find through space.
It's exactly the same as we find through time.
Now we know from climate scientists that's absolutely false,
OK, because the slope of the hill in terms
of going through time is very steep, 6 degrees
to go between ice ages when there's 1 kilometer
of ice over Chicago and over London and Boston,
London and all the rest of the western world,
6 degrees from that to our current situation. This
would imply we'd have to go from 30 degrees,
so it's completely false, but that's what they do.
Uh, ECONOMISTS think that's really clever, so they gave
him the Nobel Prize, you can see what I
think of the Nobel Prize there, and he's now
encouraging us to walk along a road that doesn't
exist. And so we're gonna walk along expecting everything's
gonna be fine and we're all gonna start dying
from the climate catastrophes that uh uh that climate
scientists have been warning about for ages and economists
trivialize by treating, What happens over space as a
proxy for what happens through time, that's why they're
so dangerous. So that's why the, the, there's, there's
no, um, no chance of persuading politicians to change
their direction at the moment. Every attempt to warn,
uh, is treated as, oh, that's just somebody being
alarmist, OK. So, OK, so but it's like watching
somebody in a car racing towards a brick wall,
and you're trying to say to them slow down
and they're saying there's no brick wall, I can't
see a brick wall. Yeah, the brick wall that
I'm looking at is uh 200 miles away, yeah.
Bang, you hit the one that's 50 m in
front of you at high speed, so you basically,
OK, what are you gonna do after you hit
the wall? And that's the situation we're in right
now.
Oh, OK, so if that is not enough to
scare people and make them really get the message,
let me just try to make this a little
bit more, uh, emotional. So, uh, I'm about, I'm
about to turn 36. I, I will turn 36
on September 26th. So, uh, the the average. Uh,
LIFESPAN in Portugal for men is 79. So let's
say that I live 43 more years until 2069,
around there. So for the rest of my life,
economically speaking, civilizationally speaking, what, what should I look
for, for, uh, what should I look forward to?
The gradual breakdown of our capacity to produce goods
and services on the planet. We'll be able, we'll
we'll continue producing them, we'll continue pumping our carbon
dioxide in terms of in response to the first
major crises that hit Western countries and killed lots
of white people. We're like to continue doing the
same thing. We're then likely to fight wars over
it like we're doing over Iran at the moment,
totally futile wars, adding military deaths to climate deaths.
So brace yourself for a far too exciting final
few years.
Uh, BUT, but the, uh, I, I mean for
these next, let's say 43 years, should we expect
already huge economic consequences and economic breakdown?
Yes. Now I I can't time and I'm not
a climate scientist. I'm going what I'm reading of
climate scientist on that front, and the only work
to sort of pretend to match the climate temperature
rise to impact on the economy is done by
economists because economists think in terms of GDP scientists
do not. So they've translated it into the terms
that that that, uh, politicians are used to thinking
about what's going to be the impact on GDP.
But because they pretend, because they believe, and this
is the trouble, ASIC sincerely believe this nonsense, they
sincerely believe that what happens across space can be
used as a proxy of what happens through time.
They are basically expecting trivial effects until 2300. OK,
you have to go that far in the future
to get any and and continue the current course
in terms of rising temperatures as well before they
get any estimates of serious damages. So for example,
William Nordhaus, who's got the Nobel Prize, bullshit Prize
for his work on climate change, he said that
3 degrees of warming by 2100 will reduce GDP
in 2100 by I think 3.12%. He was very
precise, 3.12%. Now what that means is the GDP
in 2100 according to his model would be 3.12%
lower than GDP would be in 2100 if there
was no global warming at all. That's, that's where
you get that figure from. OK, so that means
in 2100, let's say GDP now is 20, OK,
so GDP in roughly speaking, GDP in 2100, you
say will be 100 with no climate change or
97. 96.8 with 3 degrees of global warming. Now
that is such a tiny difference that we're talking
80 years in the future, that if you convert
that into a rate of economic growth, he's telling
us the 3 degrees of global warming. Will reduce
the annual rate of economic growth by about 0.01%.
Now we can't even measure modern GDP change to
that accuracy. OK. Modern, when you do it, when
you see the figures for the, for, um, GDP
growth, measured GDP growth is in 1%. He's saying
the damages from 3 degrees of warming are being
measured in 100%. Of GDP change, OK, which is
saying it's completely trivial. Only when you get to
10 or 20 degrees of warming will you see
a significant impact. Now 10 or 20 degrees of
warming, there's certainly even 6 degrees of warming, Climate
scientists say that's an existential threat to to not
just to us but to all the species on
the planet. So economists have been telling policymakers that
3 degrees are quite livable and in fact he,
when he did his Nobel Prize speech, he said
4 degrees of warming was the optimal temperature rise.
Now, climate scientists described 3 as catastrophic and 5
is 5 degrees or more as existential. So that's
the level of mismatch between what the economists are
telling politicians, what the politicians and journalists are taking
seriously, thinking, thinking, as I did before I read
the literature I might add, that the economists were
taking the work of climate scientists and turning it
into estimates of economic damages. Now I took a
look and I found that in fact they were
making this ridiculous assumption. The temperature, the temperature and
GDP relationship across space could be used to as
a proxy, what was going to happen as temperature
rose over time. Now that is like imagining that
a gully has got, has got the same shape
in all directions, OK, uh, and I use a
little analogy in this particular chapter, so imagine you're
blind and you're going for a trek from one
side of America to the other and you come
to a gully. And the, your guide, you've got
to rely on a guide, of course, and the
guide said, look, it's quite a gradual slope. It's
only 1 in 50, you can comfortably walk straight
across this gully. So you take one step and
almost almost break your neck, and you say, what
the hell, this is much steeper than you told
me it would be. What the hell did you
do? And the guide says, well, it was really
hard to survey the gully from east to west,
so I checked it out from north to south,
and I assumed it had the same shape east
to west as it has north to south. Now
you'd know you're dealing because you, because we both
have sight and we know what landforms look like,
we know that that that guy is a lunatic,
crazy, OK, OK, but economists have done exactly the
same thing. They've told us the shape of the
global warming and economic hill is the same through
time as it is through space, is it if
it's uniform, symmetrical. Now that is garbage, OK, it
is just ridiculous, but what it means is they
make trivial estimates for the damages we face, and
that's the sort of thing that's factored into all
the various official agreements, so the IPCC, um, COP
26, etc. ETC. All the damage estimates are taken
from economists, and they're so trivial that it justifies
continuing to mine fossil fuels and use them as
if we can continue doing it with very little
impact upon civilization. So I've given up being polite
about it. I thought I'd be rude in this
one and simply say, look, this is a path
to extinction, that's what we're on. Now that'll be,
that'll be put across as a lunatic and a
nutcase in the current state of discussion over these
issues. Give it 10 years if we're lucky. And
I won't be seen as a lunatic anymore.
So even if luckily this doesn't end up being
an existential threat in the sense that humanity just
goes completely extinct, if temperatures rise 2 degrees, 2
degrees, 3 degrees, 4 degrees, we're talking certainly about
billions of deaths already, right?
Yes, yes.
So I, I mean, humanity could go, uh, could,
uh, uh, could go down by, I don't know,
50% or more even,
yep, yep, that's, I mean, that's, that's, that's sort
of, you know, ballpark figures. That's the, you know,
English activist called Roger Hallam who who would have
played a major role in forming Extinction Rebellion. He's
now formed another organization called 4 Billion Deaths. And
that's trying to get people to realize this is
what we're talking about, we're not talking about a
slight decrease in GDP, OK, we're not talking about
a slight slowdown, we're talking about large numbers of
humans dying, it's two reasons, climate catastrophes which kill
them, and also, uh, the impact of climate catastrophes
on food production in particular, which will mean people
starve to death because there won't be enough food
produced at the global level. To give you an
idea of what I mean by that one, there's
one research paper published by the OECD. Which uses
a model done by Tim Linton, Tim wrote the
chapter, and they asked him to consider what would
happen with the, if the AMOC shut down. Do
you know what the AMOC stands for?
Uh, NO, not exactly.
Atlantic meridional overturning circulation. Most people mistake it for
the Gulf Stream, OK, it's what transfers warm water
from the south of the, of the Atlantic to
the north, and that makes a 10 degree difference
to the average temperature of Europe. Without that running
temperature it will fall by 10 degrees. Now Tim
did a study of what happens if the AOL
shuts down at a 2.5 degree increase in global
average temperature as well, bearing in mind that Europe
will actually get much colder because of the AOL
shutting down. And that said, there'd be a, there'd
be a fall in the area of the planet
which can support wheat, a grain, a grain of
growing, wheat and wheat and corn by 70%. So
that means a 70% decline in our capacity to
feed people. Now, we produce, we waste a fair
bit of food, we waste about 30% of what
we produce roughly speaking. So we've got a bit
of headroom, but that still means 40% of the
population is not going to get sufficient food if
it's unevenly distributed. So we have a potential famine.
On a grand scale coming out of the loss
of the AMOC and 2.5 degrees of warming. Now
people used to the climate scientists originally when they
started studying this because there was no climate science
study about what happens to in variations of temperature
to, you know, major geographic formations like the AMOC
until we started making huge changes. So the first
models started coming out in the late 1990s, early
2000s, and then those days they thought it would
take 3 to 5 degrees of warming. And and
several centuries for the process to complete. Most recent
work says 1.2 degrees of warming is enough, we're
already passed 1.2, and if it does flip, it'll
flip in 30 years, which means, uh, this is
the bizarre thing. If it, if it does, if
the AMOC does get turned off by global warming,
it's now seen as an almost certain event before
2095, and when it happens, The temperature in Europe,
and again, again this is all estimated from models,
but the temperature in Europe will fall by 3
degrees per decade for 3 decades. Now that will
mean civilization in Europe is impossible. There's no way
we, we, we have, we, we, we, we're managing
to cope with 0.0.1 or 0.0.2 increase in temperature
per decade at the moment, OK. It's not sure
causing major infrastructural changes though you saw what happened
with England with this drought just recently, so the
infrastructure is not, not, not, not designed for radical
changes in temperature. Now if the temperature is radically
changing for 3 decades at 33 degrees per decade.
Europe will just be unable to maintain its infrastructure
and it will be uninhabitable, so Europeans will be
refugees.
So we're talking about over the next few decades
potentially people in Europe, at least people I would
imagine who are already poor or part of the
middle class living in extreme poverty. Yes,
right.
Yeah, I, I mean, and, and by the way,
since, and of course this is not directly to
do with climate change, but Uh, with rising levels
of economic inequality, do you think that the living
conditions of the average person, and by that I
mean, uh, everyone who's not, let's say, a centimillionaire
or a billionaire, uh, will, will decrease even further
and people will be even more impacted by, uh,
the economic consequences of climate change.
Yeah, well, at some stage we, we, we can't
allow the market system to set incomes anymore because
we're going to, with climate change, it's on that
scale and people face starvation. If they, if, if
we leave it to the market price, market price
is to be set, then food will be too
expensive for the poor. Now we know what the
last time that happened we called it the French
Revolution. OK, OK, um, so you you I think
frankly there was more capacity to make those sorts
of changes in, in the, you know, previous centuries
than now obviously because the, at least the, the
public could carry equivalent weapons to the, except for
cannons, equivalent weapons to the forces they were fighting.
Well now, of course, we're you know humans are
completely outclassed by by their security forces and most
of the planet. Um, SO, uh, I don't expect
a possibility for Porter overthrow in that situation, I
don't expect a repeat of the French Revolution on
that front, but there will be social breakdown if,
if you leave it to the market system and
food gets too expensive for people on the bottom,
say 20% of the population to afford or 20,
30%, then there'll be riots. And, and this is
the sort of world that we're on the edge
of.
By the way, before we move on to the
war in Iran, let me just ask you about
this because particularly in recent years, probably this is
older than just recent years, but Uh, I've been
hearing from some people who I think we could
label as climate change skeptics that, oh, OK, climate
change, it, it, it is bad for most of
the world, but actually if you, if we look
at the numbers of people who live in colder
areas. Actually, climate change can help them because, uh,
because the, um, the temperatures get warmer where they
live and so, uh, deaths by cold do not
occur as much. I mean, I've been hearing arguments
like that. I mean, what,
what idiots, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly. Uh,
Bjorn Lomborg will happily, uh, dive inside a scientific
paper and pull it apart and point out errors
and what he sees as errors and statistical indiscrepancies.
He never pulls apart the economist. He just says,
look, the Nobel Prize winning economist tells us X,
Y, and Z. If you look at the work
that Nordhaus has done, it's garbage. Uh, IT'S, it's
pulling apart a scientific paper you've got to read
a look to find something you might regard as
a flaw. Pulling apart, uh, Nordhaus's work, an, an
eight year old child could do it. The reason
being that he makes simple, uh, logical errors which
are ludicrous, but economists let him get away with
it, and Longborg doesn't even mention. So for example,
when he, when Nordhaus tried first tried to impact
to, to guess. What he thought the impact of
3 degrees of warming would be by 2100, he
came out that it would cause GDP in 2100
to fall by 0.25 of 1%. So rather than
like being rather than being 100 being 100 because
of 3 degrees, it'll be 99.75, OK. So that
was one in terms of a prediction of the
decline in the rate of economic growth because of
3 degrees of warming, it's about 0.001%, almost unmeasurable,
OK. That's that now now in that he had
a, what he did was he had a table
of industries that are severely exposed, moderately exposed, and
negligibly exposed to climate change, and he had water
transportation in the moderately exposed category. He had road
transportation in negligibly exposed. OK. He had mining in
negligibly exposed. OK, then somebody pointed out to him
that what about open cut mining? So he'd reduced
his estimate by 2%, so that rather than 87%
of industry being uh negligibly affected, it'll be 85%.
He took across, took out the 2% related to
uh open uh open cut mining. But what he
basically was doing, it's quite obvious, he's mistaking the
weather for climate. He's thinking if you're exposed to
the weather, therefore you're exposed to climate change. If
you happen under a roof or undercover as underground
mining does, you won't be affected by climate change.
That was his thinking. Now roads. So far as
I'm aware, are exposed to the climate, they're exposed
to the weather. He assumed they were negatively affected.
OK, that's a juvenile error. OK, an eight year
old could have said, hang on, aren't roads exposed?
Shouldn't they be with water transportation and at least
moderately affected, OK, so it's, it's that bad work.
That he put together and he said that he
couldn't see anything that was going to affect manufacturing
or services, well, unless there's one factory making all
the goods on the planet, you need roads to
connect different factories together. So if the roads are
exposed and roads are affected, and so is manufacturing
going to be. He didn't factor that in. Yeah,
so they were simply trying to find ways to
trivialize the dangers we face because according to economists,
the market can solve all problems. So therefore climate
change can't be a big problem. That's really was
the thinking. So they then use numbers across space
where vary vary varying your latitude has a minor
effect upon how much GDP can be created in
that latitude. You get wealthy countries in hot regions
like Singapore and, And equally wealthy countries in in
cold, cold regions like like uh Boston, um, They,
that's basically implies there's not much relationship between temperature
and GDP across across space. They've said therefore there's
not much of a relationship between temperature and GDP
across time either. And that's it's completely wrong, but
that's, that's the basis of the guidance they've given
us that climate change is a trivial problem. Yeah,
so let's talk a little bit about the war
in Iran, and of course I want to tackle
it with you more from an economics perspective. So,
uh, what has been and what could be the
impact on the global market and on the global
economy? I mean, what could be the impact of
this war?
Well, we're losing about 10% of our oil. Coming
through the Strait of Iran, Strait of the Strait
of um um um Hormuz, yeah, and 30% of
our fertilizer, about 30% or more of uh helium,
a large proportion of sulfur dioxide, all these things
are essential inputs to production processes. Now, when we
run out of the stocks of those products, then
our capacity to produce goods and services that need
those inputs will decline. So in terms of energy,
it's about maybe 3% of global energy, that implies
a 3% fall in global GDP and the other
factors will turn up in all sorts of industries
and make it very difficult for firms that have
have uh working capital debts to be able to
service their debts because they can't make the goods
to sell them anymore. Uh, THERE'LL be a complete
drop in the volume of sales they can make.
The price will increase a bit but not enough
to compensate, so we can expect bankruptcies coming out
of that, and we can also expect that many
goods and services will end up in short supply.
Now that includes things like microchips and copper, for
example, microchips need helium, chopper needs sulfuric acid. If
we have this, if this war's going to continue
until Donald Trump dies, I think that's obvious. All
the talk about it ending, uh, it's, it's not
a temporary shutdown of the Strait of Hormuz, it's
a permanent one until Donald Trump dies. Now that
means we can face maybe another couple of years
of this, if he, if he, if he lives
until the end of his term, which is possible,
um, then we have another 2 years of this
restriction. On output from the Strait of Hormuz, and
that will ultimately exhaust all the stocks we've used
so far to avoid immediate consequences. So one of
the reasons that oil is still available, even though
it's now finally getting more expensive, is that China
ran down its reserves quite radically. It had 1.5
years' worth of reserves. It ran it down. Now
they're rebuilding them. Um, THAT those stocks will certainly
be exhausted except for China by the time we
get to another 2 years from now, and when
that happens, uh, we then we'll be basically living
with 2 or 3% less energy. And there's a
one for one link between energy and GDP, uh,
we'll have less sulfur, we can't produce, we'll probably
be able to make some substitutions there, but sulfur's
produced as a byproduct of, of mining oil in
the first instance, so you need to have oil
producers producing oil to make the sulfur in the
first instance, uh, but they'll lose that capacity, we'll
lose the helium, uh, the helium is something which
once it's used, it disappears from the planet. You
can't, you can't store it indefinitely, so all these
essential inputs will disappear. And not the whole lot,
not the complete, uh, proportion, there is some capacity
to compensate for production systems elsewhere, but it really
means serious disruption to the global economy.
Looking at the oil crisis that occurred in the
1970s, and we all know, of course, the economic
consequences and the rise of neoliberalism that occurred in
the aftermath of it, I mean, do you think
that this could be similar in Level even worse
or it's similar, similar in level. I mean, people
people forget history, but the oil price was $2.50
a barrel before the 1973 war and $10 a
barrel after it, and then it went from $10
a barrel to $40 in 1979, 191,980. So that
is, you know, an enormous increase in the price
of oil, and that's what caused the inflationary surge
at the time. Uh, IT, it isn't necessarily the
same, it's, it's a similar scale. I think I've
seen estimates saying it's slightly larger in terms of
impact on the supply of oil globally, but it's
that sort of scale, and, uh, the only reason
we haven't had the impact drastically at the moment
is that is the existence of stocks in China
in particular, selling its stocks onto the global market,
which therefore made up for the decline in in
passage through the Strait of Hormuz.
And of course we're talking here about not only
a reduction in the supply of oil and of
course gasoline and diesel going up, people paying more
for it, but also not only through the products
you mentioned their, their supply going down, but even
is That also has eventually an impact on the
supply of essential items that people need like food,
etc. OR at least their prices going up, going
up substantially.
Not just prices, I mean this is about 30%
of the world's fertilizer passes through the Strait of
Horz. Again, I'm not, I'm not an expert, I'm
taking numbers off colleagues of mine who are more
experts on this right, that's what they told me,
roughly 30%. Uh, THAT means at least a 30%
fall in global food supply. Now at the moment
we produce 30% more than we need, that's how
much we waste in production and distribution systems, but
that's, we're we're not going to be 100% efficient
with the remainder, absolutely no way. So that means
we're going to have less food than is necessary
to keep the total population of the planet alive,
which means there'll be famines. And it's if you,
there'll be the most likely that those occur mainly
in third world countries because prices will be up
to the stage where they can't import the food
they need. Uh, BUT it could also happen in
countries like the UK. They could be forced into
food rationing. And I hope that happens, frankly, because
this is the wake-up call that people need. If
you had to have food rationing in the UK,
I think we were holy hell, what's happening here.
This doesn't sound trivial to me anymore. So something
of that nature, uh, that, that's the most polite
wake-up call we could get of countries that have
never had to consider food rationing except during times
of war. Of course, the UK had rationing during
World War II. To suddenly find they've got to
do it during peacetime, it might make people realize,
hey holy shit this is serious, at the moment
we're still treating it as trivial.
OK, so I mean, let me ask you about
this because I've read pieces that are the most
optimistic things I've ever read in my life where
people have been suggesting or proposing that, OK, so
maybe this oil crisis will trigger an acceleration of
the transformation of our energy system and people buy.
More electric cars, electric vehicles, because they can no
longer afford gasoline or diesel, and maybe this will
have a positive impact when it comes to climate
change. I mean, do you think that's real? Oh,
that's, that's valid.
That's valid. I mean, what has actually happened is
that one of the climate denier was to say,
you know, when they trivialize renewables, they say, well,
the wind doesn't always blow, but the sun doesn't
always shine and the wind doesn't always blow. Well,
now we can say the Strait of Hormuz doesn't
always flow. And it points out how dangerous it
is to rely upon such a volatile part of
the world for a large part of our global
energy needs. The Middle East, I mean, it is,
it wasn't necessarily as bad as it's turned out
to be because America's meddling has made things far
worse, but you can have a hard time finding
a less politically stable region of the world to
have an essential commodity coming out of than the
Middle East. So now the people are saying, hell,
you can't rely upon the petrol anymore, even if
the solar is, you know, weaker and I've got
a charge overnight and all this sort of jazz,
it's better to have the reliability, at least, at
least the sun will ultimately shine and the wind
will ultimately blow. We still don't know when the
Strait of Homoz is going to flow again, so
I think it does, it has had an impact,
but whether it's sufficient to get us to zero
carbon output, no. Uh, WE'LL still, we still use
coal for, uh, coal-fired power stations. We still use
gas-powered power stations for, for power, and when we
use, uh, we have to use the huge amounts
of fossil fuels for producing things like concrete and
steel and so on. So those uses are still
there, still involving burning carbon. So, uh, if, if
it, it will accelerate, but we're moving so slowly
already. That the potential for that to replace roughly
roughly 85% of our energy comes from fossil fuels,
no, I can't see that having that level of
an impact.
Mhm. So let me just ask you one final
question, and this is a broader question about the
global economy and because we've seen that just a
single country getting affected can really have a huge
impact on the global market. I mean, with looking
at how the global economy is structured nowadays, do
you think that There's any possibility that a major
economy, if a major economy gets affected, like for
example, I don't know, Germany, France, the UK, the
US, that another major economy like China has any
possibility of being insulated from the, the economic reverberations
of that.
Like you're the only country I think that's gonna
be gonna be um. Insulated to some degree as
China, because when you look at their, their, their
plans, I really think that the the underlying a
lot of what they're doing is the, the sort
of cultural memory that China has what they call
the century of humiliation. When the people, Westerners have
no idea of what happened to China in the
19th century, uh, the opium wars, I'm sure most
Westerners think the opium wars a fight to keep
those nasty Chinese from selling opium to the West.
Of course it was the exact opposite. It was
the West finding they couldn't get anything that China
needed to buy. China's industry was far higher quality
than the Western industries were. That's why we call
crockery China, OK. West western China, OK, is that
the, the Chinese stuff was far higher quality than
the Western. So in those early days before the
century of humiliation, there was an enormous trade imbalance
between the rest of the world and China. China's
exports far exceeded China's imports. Does that sound familiar?
OK, at the moment, um, what then was that
meant that they, they were paying, West was paying
for the goods mainly in silver. Also gold but
mainly silver, so Western silver stocks were plunging. China,
the British then realized they could sell opium into
China and they started smuggling it into China. Through,
through their little enclaves, and the Chinese tried to
stop it, and the the British fought the war
to maintain the right to sell opium to Chinese
and force them in fact to consume it in
some cases. So what you have is basically the
West was drug pushers to the east. Now, and
that destroyed Chinese culture, put them into a horrible
century, about 90 years of between the um uh
beginning of the Opium War and the and the
uh end of the Chinese revolution. They call that
the century of humiliation. Kids learn that in school.
So anybody in the Politburo who has been through
learning that experience, it teaches them do not trust
the West, OK, and it teaches them to be
self-sufficient. So I think that's a large part, even
going beyond any 55 year planning, I think it's
a major focus of China to not be to
make sure they're as independent as they possibly can
be. So that means that even though they're getting
there, it's, it's a huge task to go from
being a fossil fuel powered country to a nuclear
and renewable fuel country, but they're more likely to
make it than anybody else, and they're more self-contained.
The big weaknesses that they don't produce enough food
for their entire population. And they don't have enough
fossil fuel energy, of course, but it's all the
more reason why they're likely to go to nuclear
and renewables. So I think China's got a chance
of surviving. I wouldn't back anybody else.
OK, so, uh, uh, let me just ask you
this. If I want to really plan long term,
I mean, plan for the rest for the 3
years of my life, should I move to China
or should I move to a hunter-gatherer society?
Depends on your tastes, um, when the hunter-gatherer, I,
I reckon, uh, Papua New Guineans are going to
do fine because they're Highlanders and they're already hunter-gatherers,
they'll survive, OK, um, so you've got a choice
New Guinea or um or China, and uh yeah
I think I'll choose China.
OK, OK, so Doctor Kim, thank you so much
for taking the time to come on the show
again. And where can people find you and your
work on
the internet, YouTube, my YouTube channel at Prof Steve
Keen. I have my sub stack and my Patreons
also the same. uh, Prof Steve Keen is part
of the name for Patreon and Substack, uh, and
I'm doing an online course these days, which I'm
actually reorganizing right now. My marketing company, uh, disappeared.
So I'm having to replace them, which is a
difficult, but it's also a good thing. It means
I can make the marketing more consistent with what
I actually deliver. But that's at Steve Keen.com. So
if you go to that, you go, it's, it's
a complicated, um, very commercial oriented funnel right now.
I hope to replace it over time with the
one talking about learning alternative economics, but that's, so
those three sources are Steve Keen.com for the online
course and a prof Steve Keen for YouTube, Patreon,
and SubStack.
OK, great. I will be leaving links to that
and look, it's been a fascinating conversation as always,
and I really love your work, so I wish
you all the best and thank you for coming
on the show.
Thanks, Ricardo, pop me that collaboration link too if
you wouldn't mind, so.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at enlights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Muller, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingbird, Arnaud Wolf, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forrest Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerru Inasi Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andrea, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoo, and
Hal Herzognon, Michel Jonathan Labrarinth, John Yardston, and Samuel
Curric Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel, Sardusran,
David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezaraujo Romain Roach, Diego Londono
Correa. Yannik Punteran Ruzmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro, Adam
Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alekbaka, Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov, Zal
Adrian Yei Poltontin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward Hall,
Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolotti, Gabriel P Scortez
or Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy, Sony Smith,
and Wiseman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg Jarno,
Luke Lovai, Georgios Theophanous, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin, David
Williams, Di Acosta, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex Shaw,
Marie Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D. Lee
Junior. Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber, Robert
Grassy, Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix, Mark
Kempel, Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly Johnson,
Benjamin Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael
Bensleyman. George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate Van
Goler, Alexander Obert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali Mohammadi,
Perpendicular, Jannes Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov,
Sean Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A special
thanks to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank Lucas
Stinnik, Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas
Trumbull, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlo Montenegro, Al
Nick Cortiz, and Nick Golden, and to my executive
producers, Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and Rosie.
Thank you for all.